Big news overnight.
Donald Trump's personal lawyer, 76 year old
Rudy Giuliani, has tested positive for coronavirus.
Donald Trump confirming the diagnosis via
Twitter yesterday, saying, quote, Rudy Giuliani
by far the greatest mayor in the history of
New York City and who has been working tirelessly
exposing the most corrupt election by far
in the history of the United States, has tested
positive for the China virus, back to calling
it the China virus.
Get better soon, Rudy.
We will carry on.
And now, of course, there is nothing surprising
about this.
Rudy Giuliani has been flying daily all over
the country for weeks, sitting in rooms with
100 or more different people every day, many
without masks, all to promote bogus voter
fraud conspiracies.
The only surprising thing about Rudy and Coronavirus
is it took this long for Rudy to test positive.
So there's a few elements to this story.
First is the personal health element.
Rudy 76.
At minimum, he's overweight.
I don't know if he would be considered obese,
unsure about other comorbidities.
So question one is, how serious of a case
will Rudy have?
And as with everybody, I hope he gets to experience
a full and speedy recovery.
Many people do not.
That's question one.
Part two, how many people did Rudy Giuliani
expose or give the virus to in the days prior
to the positive test?
He was all over different hearings without
a mask around lawmakers from different states,
also not wearing masks next to another Trump,
Attorney General Ellis also without a mask.
So he may be another super spreader.
Arizona's legislature has shut down because
they were all exposed by Rudy Giuliani just
a few days ago.
That's part number two.
Part number three, how does this impact Trump's
continued voter fraud campaign?
Will they keep having hearings and filing
bogus legal complaints with other attorneys
working for them?
Will Rudy work from home?
Who knows?
Rudy, as of last night, had been checked into
a hospital for treatment.
And then fourth, and this is just amazing,
the number of people convinced that this is
actually part of the conspiracy is stunning.
I jokingly tweeted yesterday, and anyone who
knows me knows it's obvious satire.
I posted to Twitter a fake conspiratorial
post.
Again, obviously joking.
I said, quote, Doesn't anybody find it a little
suspicious that just as Rudy was traveling
all over the country ready to expose affidavits
that would overturn the election, he gets
covid and now has to stop exposing the fraud.
It's too convenient.
Now, that was a joke.
And somehow this tweet got caught in some
kind of Twitter trending topics thing and
people were agreeing with me.
People responded, yeah, it is a bit of a stretch.
A woman named Marlene responded, Yep.
And I don't believe Trump had it either.
A woman named Debbie suggested Rudy doesn't
really have covid.
But that quote, I wonder if Trump sidelined
him because of all the losing.
It got so bad that I had to post a follow
up tweet where I said, holy, you know what?
I can't believe I have to add this, but my
post is satire, you lunatics.
So that's very, very bad.
And of course, we wish Rudy the best and a
full recovery.
And at the same time, we hope that he will
drop the bogus voter fraud nonsense because
it's been so, so corrosive to democracy.
Rudy Giuliani positive for coronavirus and
in the hospital.
And we now must discuss Georgia, Georgia,
which will determine who ends up controlling
the Senate on January 20th.
Let's
go
to that next.